today i want to talk about mr morale and
the big steppers i hope you'll find
some peace of mind the newest album from
the man the myth the legend kendrick
lamar
i tend to start these videos with a
background on the artist but the
background here is that it's kendrick
lamar
you'd have to be living under several
rocks to not know who this guy is but
i'll give you a little background on my
experience with kendrick in short i'm a
big fan i've been a fan of kendrick and
everybody on the td roster for years now
good kid mad city was great and of
course my love was solidified with te
pimpa butterfly probably one of the best
albums ever made fun fact about tapima
butterfly if you look at wikipedia it'll
tell you that it came out on march 15th
of 2015. in reality it leaked at about
11 pm eastern on the 15th and then
officially released at 1am eastern so it
did not come out on the 15th it came out
on march 16th 2015 as a birthday present
for myself and danny brown
the following year he released untitled
unmastered supposedly cutting room floor
stuff from to pippa butterfly and man
that album that album's underrated it's
very very good he just continued to push
in this weird jazzy sonic direction that
i love and then he released damn which
yeah look i'm not personally a fan of
damn i think it's a bit too commercial
for my taste and it also features some
of the weakest hooks he's ever had i
feel like a lot of people would consider
that a hot take so let's not dwell on
that we've had five years to dwell on
that album in the lead up to this album
he releases the heart part 5 the latest
entry in a series of singles that does
not make the album and it's very jazzy
so i'm getting my hopes up thinking even
if we're not necessarily going in that
direction again we're probably going
less commercial which for me is good we
also find out that it is a double album
with an image that kendrick teases and
that for me is a red flag right away
because i don't need an album that long
double album could be a lot of things
double album could be drake's scorpion
nobody needs an album that long
thankfully what we get is a double album
only in spirit whereas technically it is
just an album because it fits on a cd my
first impression listening to this was
pretty wild for context i actually put
it on while i was starting a brand new
world in minecraft dying repeatedly
trying to find a place to stake as my
own and in the background i'm hearing a
lot of strange things definitely a
departure from the commercial sound a
lot of outlandish musical choices
there's a dark song with kendrick
explaining how he's racist there's
multiple appearances from the disgraced
and disgraceful kodak black kendrick's
got bars about cancel culture and
wokeness that had me worried he was
entering his unbearable joe rogan era
and then there's we cry together how am
i supposed to respond to that it's a
domestic dispute soundtracked by a
griselda beat
[Music]
i finished it out i started the album
again from the top and by the end of the
second listen everything was starting to
click for me i realized what most people
probably realized by now that the album
is kendrick going through therapy in a
way of course all art is a form of
therapy but rarely is it this blatant i
mean here kendrick has us listening to
the things he's presumably telling to
his therapist immediately my mind
compares it to kanye's yay because that
album is billed as a therapy album and
it features a similar progression the
progression makes a lot of sense
starting from the opening of the album
which features kendrick telling us that
i've been going through something so the
first half of the album is actually the
big stepper half
what is a big stepper well we hear this
idea throughout the album of stop tap
dancing around the issues i think the
big stepper is sort of the actual self
the average person trying to be tough in
their environment and not taking the
time to consider what they've been
through or consider the way certain
things have impacted them the first half
of the album or the first album since
this is technically a double it's a lot
about the actual self and kendrick's
environment and throughout that first
half we see a lot of unhealthy behaviors
i think that's why we have kodak black
in there for an interlude we've got the
bizarre worldwide steppers and of course
we've got we cry together which is
extremely toxic i'm paraphrasing this
from a tweet but if you're in a
relationship that sounds like that track
you should break up there are a lot of
great tracks on that first half of the
album but personally i found it to be a
little weaker just because it has some
of those more poppy commercial songs
that would have fit on damn and while i
know those are favorites for a lot of
people it just doesn't connect with me
like that for me the second half is
where things get really interesting
where the first was the big steppers the
second half is mr morale mr morrow
who is mr morale it's an idealized
version of kendrick right the back half
of the album is kendrick embracing his
flaws and trying to improve himself mr
morale could be that kendrick is trying
to push himself into a place of morality
or it could be that he's recognizing
that everybody puts him on that pedestal
so he's embracing his flaws his
fallibility and understanding where and
how he needs to grow as a person or the
first half dealt with a lot of
environmental things and forces outside
of himself this one is a lot about
himself and his family and that's why
where on the first we had kodak black as
sort of a proxy for kendrick here we
have baby keem who's literally closer
because he's related there's really some
amazing tracks in this back half i've
got to talk about auntie diaries which
personally is one of my favorites on the
whole album but it's a little
controversial kendrick's confronting his
views about trans people and how those
views have progressed through a number
of family members kendrick swaps
pronouns in and out for his relatives
and kendrick uses a certain word that i
honestly don't need to repeat for you to
know what i'm talking about
but yeah he uses it quite a bit of
course he uses it to illustrate his old
self right his younger self who was
careless with the words he threw around
but could he have gotten his point
across without it i'm not sure i do
think it's abrasive and a little clunky
but you know what it's a very
interesting attempt to do so and it's
tricky but it's important and regardless
of what side you stand on man the track
is beautiful i mean the instrumental the
way it builds toward the end is just so
empowering and then there's mother i
sober shortly after that which again
very heavy track very personal details
kendrick talking about generational
curses abuse in his family
addiction kendrick has a tendency to
inhabit characters in his music he's
done so in the past and even here with
mr morale i mean that's a character but
with songs like auntie diaries and
mother i sober this feels like the
closest we've gotten to the core of
kendrick lamar and who he really is it's
an extremely personal album and i
applaud him for exploring these topics
it's obviously a very public way of
discussing these things that i'm sure
he's discussed privately in therapy or
with his family but hey at least he can
say he's no longer tap dancing around
the issues so really the thesis of this
album becomes apparent in some of the
last few tracks kendrick telling us
things like he is not our savior and
he's choosing himself kendrick made you
think about it but he is not your savior
i really love the closer where he talks
about sorry i couldn't save the world
you know i had to work on myself it
could be hard for us to remember that
artists are people especially when we
put them on a high pedestal i mean we're
talking about a guy who won a pulitzer
prize for what i think is his worst
album that's another hot take but hey
you can't please everybody
when i first saw the album i was struck
by the fact that he's wearing what seems
to be a crown of thorns but on closer
inspection it's not actually a crown of
thorns it's a jewelry piece this of
course has been confirmed as we've seen
him wearing it in performances since but
it's also displayed pretty clearly
inside the jewel case if you buy the cd
there's something to be said about
kendrick having a god complex if he's
comparing himself to jesus but i don't
think it's that simple i just told you
who i thought i was a god obviously a
crown of thorns is a symbol we associate
with jesus but why is this one iced out
why is this a jewelry piece instead of
an actual crown well i think it has
something to do with kendrick telling us
that he's not our savior the fact that
it's iced out the fact that it's covered
in diamonds and is a jewelry piece to me
suggests that it wasn't put there by
kendrick but by the culture of hip-hop
you know diamond jewelry and expensive
chains are a frequent image in hip-hop
and some wear one with a face of jesus
this is what is often called a jesus
piece kendrick's crown here is sort of a
different kind of jesus piece you know
kendrick seems to have been labeled as a
god by hip-hop fans by the culture at
large anytime some old head rapper comes
out talking about the future of rap and
how they feel confident they all name
drop kendrick talk to joey earl can you
decode gatekeepers if you ain't kendra
i mean kendrick did once label himself
the king of both coasts but does he view
himself as the savior of hip-hop
probably not especially not at this
point and yet he wears the iced out
crown of thorns not by choice but
because that's the position that he's
been given so the thesis of this album
kind of reminds me of frank ocean's line
and future of free i'm just a guy i'm
not a god
[Music]
kendrick's just some guy who makes music
the same way i'm some guy making videos
of course he's better at what he does
but yeah kendrick's telling us that he's
been going through something for the
last five years and with the weight of
the world on his shoulders it's probably
been really hard for him to decide what
he would do next how he would fulfill
the role that we've given him the shoes
have probably gotten too big for his
feet comparing this to frank ocean i
think there's a parallel there you know
with another guy who doesn't drop music
very frequently how often over the last
five years did we hear people talking
about when's kendrick gonna drop how
often do we continue to hear when is
frank ocean gonna drop a new album for
me hearing kendrick talk about these
things it's a fresh reminder that i
don't like the idea of pushing an artist
i don't think we should sit around
asking when are you going to drop
another album you know they're artists
who make art and live in the public eye
but they are still people and they've
got their own things going on at all
times so yeah as frequent as it is that
you see people just flooding the replies
to a tweet for a big artist asking them
to drop new music maybe we shouldn't do
that maybe we should just appreciate the
work that they've given us so far and
look forward to what's coming next
but let them work at their own pace
not everybody's griselda don't
finally something i want to talk about
here at the end is album sales i've seen
a lot of discussion around this album in
particular with people looking at
kendrick sales first week and saying
that he fell off i had someone tell me i
fell off who i needed i don't know what
the number is i don't really care to
look it up it's not really my business
what the label is making off of their
artists but of course you know somebody
takes five years to make an album
they're probably not gonna sell as well
as they once did especially when an
artist follows their most commercial
release ever with their most personal
statement ever yeah there's not going to
be as much sale potential but honestly
who cares we're talking about art here
kendra had a lot to get off his chest
here a lot of weight to lift off his
shoulders and of course it took him a
long time because he was going through a
lot do you think he cares how much money
the album made it would be like if i
came up to you and said hey i've been
going through a lot lately and i finally
feel like i've turned my life around and
your only response is okay great but how
much money are you making i feel like
i've said this in multiple videos now
but art is forever and an album like
this is going to persist it might not be
something you listen to all the time
because it is heavy but it's going to be
there forever in the grand scheme of
things 5 10 20 years from now when you
go back and listen to this what what is
the first week sales have anything to do
with anything hey you can't please
everybody
final thoughts yeah i love this album
it's probably going to be my number one
of the year i don't think anything is
going to unseat it but we'll see all i
know is i really love the statement that
kendrick made with this one and i love
the fact that it didn't go as commercial
as dan i just have a great appreciation
for artists who reach the level that he
has and are still willing to take risks
thanks everyone for watching and
speaking of artists taking risks i think
i'm going to listen to that new drake
album again